the way to understand transgenderism i
made this argument during my speech at
washburn which if you missed it it was
really wonderful to be at washburn
university we had a capacity room they
actually added 50 more chairs to the
room just to try to squeeze people in
but there were 200 people who were
turned away at the door was a really
really great event
the thesis of my speech was that
transgenderism needs to be rejected
entirely and that it doesn't make any
sense on the biological level on the
psychological level and on the
theological level that transgenderism is
actually a religious movement that draws
on themes of gnostic dualism and i've
laid out my argument for that and the
libs will tell you you're crazy you're
insane it's not a religious movement at
all transgenderism it's it's not
religious it's purely biological and
then they post videos like this
hi everyone
i just wanted to get on here to say
happy visibility day to my trans queer
and non-binary family
i feel so honored to be able to
celebrate this day
my name is lavender lou
um in my mid-20s i am currently
you know posted up in some stolen
multnomah lands i identify as two-spirit
and have my relationship with my divine
masculine and my divine feminine are
very omnipresent every single day i have
very much an embodiment of male and
female energy that
doesn't sway
to all my other trans family i want you
to know that i see you
that i love you
that this universe is undergoing an
immense reconstruction right now but
that we've got this
so take that christians take that you
bible thumpers get your religion out of
my scientific transgenderism movement in
which i am a two-spirit with my divine
masculine and my divine feminine energy
because the energy man the energy's
moving in the universe this is the
dawning of the age of aquarius because
that's science right you saw that did
you see the two spirits under the
microscope
did you did you see the divine
masculine through the telescope in the
no probably you didn't
it's obviously a religious movement
this is where conservatives go a little
wrong too because we'll some we use this
phrase biological male i get we
practically people do it because if we
don't bend the knee in any way to
transgenderism the libs can just
completely kick us out of the public
square shut down for all intents
purposes shut down conservative outlets
kick us off of social media tactically i
get why sometimes people use it but it's
dumb it's not going to work it concedes
the premise of transgenderism that you
can be biologically male but
psychologically female or something like
that and moreover when we try to argue
against transgenderism from the
perspective of science we completely
lose the argument because it is not in
any way a scientific movement it's a
movement about the relationship of the
soul to the body about two spirits and
divine masculine and you know what i'm
talking about man
so good apply the rigor of theology to
it theology is faith-seeking
understanding theology isn't some
made-up fantastical nonsense quite the
opposite actually theology takes made-up
fantastical nonsense and applies logic
and applies rigor to it and says okay if
we're thinking just as in science there
are lots of superstitions in science and
then you apply rigorous examination to
discard the superstitions about the
physical world and figure out what's
really going on so too that's what
theology does to the metaphysical world
and if you don't if you're not willing
to use that express kind of language
then you're gonna end up in the gobbledy
group of two spirits and divine
masculine and and the energy man you're
gonna end up sounding like joe biden and
nobody wants to do that right now go to
thuma dot co
slash
knowles
your bedroom deserves a refresh
your
room your home really matters a lot of
people don't think about it especially
guys but when you are in a place
either that place is going to slightly
elevate your spirits or it's going to
slightly lower your spirits okay and
you're probably not even going to be
conscious of it so help elevate your
spirits right now go check out the bed
by thuma hand crafted from eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood you will find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain they have a minimalist
design features japanese joinery
it will be super supportive for your
mattress it's breathable made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space it's made for how you live the bed
by thuma is backed with a lifetime
warranty ships right to your door in
three easy to maneuver boxes takes about
five ish minutes to assemble with no
tools required you can do it all by
yourself along with the bed suma offers
all sorts of other bedroom essentials
the nightstand the side table the tray
or perfect compliments create that
feeling of checking in to your favorite
boutique hotel suite but at home with
the bed by thuma go to thuma dot co co
slash knowles and use code knowles to
receive a 25 credit toward your purchase
of the bed plus free shipping in the
continental u.s that's t-h-u-m-a dot c-o
slash knowles k-w-l-e-s enter knowles at
checkout for 25 dollar credit zuma dot
co slash knowles enter code knowles
i'm glad you liked that clip now
subscribe ring the bell get
notifications head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitcher or
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knoll show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]